bonjour bonjour à tous bienvenue sur
public sénat bienvenue dans dialogue
citoyen nous sommes ensemble pendant une
heure et demie neuf citoyens et
citoyennes connecter depuis les quatre
coins du pays six sénateurs et
sénatrices et lu un peu partout en
france tous venus en tout cas échanger
autour de l'état de notre démocratie
fragilisé fatigués certains durant même
malade
nous sommes en tout cas à quelques jours
de nouvelles échéances électorales et on
sait déjà que beaucoup n'iront pas voter
pour quoi que se passe-t-il d'où vient
cette perte de confiance ce nous donnons
la parole ce soir à des français qui ont
été déçus qu'ils n'y croient plus qui
ont choisi de faire de la politique
autrement
sans forcément passer par les voies
traditionnelles les élus de la haute
assemblée sauront-ils répondre à cette
défiance nous les entendrons dans un
instant ce dialogue cet échange vous
pouvez le suivre et le commentée sur les
réseaux sociaux hashtag dialogue citoyen
sur twitter il est également diffusé sur
la page facebook de public sénat et en
direct sur youtube
sachez enfin que ce programme est
disponible pour les sourds et
malentendants
avant de vous présenter tous nos invités
quelques images d'un citoyen qui s'est
longtemps engagé en politique mais qui
en ressort très déçu
je m'appelle baptiste touchon tu as des
ardennes j'ai été militant pendant
plusieurs années
longtemps près de vingt ans je me suis
engagé au sein du parti socialiste pour
ses valeurs ses principes
1 sa capacité à rassembler majorité nos
concitoyens en 2012 on accède enfin tout
bois avec ce monsieur à la tête mais les
et dès 2012 des renoncements que des
revirements raku de 49,3 en 2016
ottawa travail je me retrouve à
manifester contre le gouvernement auquel
j'ai contribué à mettre au pouvoir
la suite à bien on est secrétaire à
l'elysée
merci à la suite d'un monsieur hollande
monsieur macron est aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui reste en france qu'est ce
qui reste comme valeur qu'est ce qui
reste comme tracy qu'est-ce que
une fois est bien plus grand chose gardé
à l'image de ces panneaux des taureaux
la veille d'une élection sous vide
et on vous retrouve baptiste touchon
bienvenue vous avez donc 39 ans vous
habitez à signy-l'abbaye dans les
ardennes vous faites partie on l'a
compris des grandes issus de la
politique
vous y avez cru un temps vous y avait
même participé en tant que militant au
ps et à la france insoumise
mais vous n'y avait pas trouvé votre
compte vous avez ensuite rejoint les
gilet jaune mais cela n'a pas donné
assez de résultats selon vous du coup
aujourd'hui vous ne croyez qu'à la
révolution vous nous expliquerez tout
cela dans un instant benoît beaudry est
également avec nous bien venu vous avez
52 ans vous venez de marseille vous êtes
demandeur d'emploi vous faites partie
des citoyens membres de la convention
pour le climat vous n'étiez pas
spécialement écolo mais cette expérience
vous a quand même chamboulé vous dites
que vous avez pris une gifle
aujourd'hui vous êtes déçu par ce qui en
ressort vous nous en direz plus dans un
instant alexandre ngogo bienvenue à vous
également vous avez 26 ans vous êtes
directeur de projet dans l'événementiel
et dans l'univers des jeux vidéo
vous venez de tarbes dans les
hautes-pyrénées en 2017 vous avez voté
très à gauche au premier tour au second
tour vous avez joué le jeu de ce qu'on
appelle le front républicain pour
stopper marine le pen
mais vous le dit aujourd'hui et vous
l'assumez clairement ce front
républicain
on ne vous y reprendra plus avec vous
pour échanger ce soir xavier iacovelli
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur en marche
des hauts-de-seine membre de la
commission des affaires sociales jacques
fernique bienvenue à vous également vous
êtes sénateur écologiste du bas-rhin
vice président de la commission des
affaires européennes et membre de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
baptiste touchon on va commencer avec
vous on l'a entendu un la politique
vous n'y croyez plus pour vous la
démocratie ne marche pas elles ne
marchent pas bien dans notre pays
expliquez nous comment vous en êtes
arrivé à ce niveau de défiance
bonjour bonjour à vos invités comprend
très facilement quand on s'engage d'un
parti socialiste au sein du parti ce
seuil c'est toujours ces principes c'est
une excellent choix
les vidéos mission et on fait exactement
est ce au détriment des personnes tuées
donc voilà elle n'est pas français en
2012 il y avait encore un on pouvait
espérer un changement du candidat promet
il s'était engagé sur elle dit
il les a tenus alors que dans son brevet
c'était le gamin je m'engagerai les
conséquences elles ont été pour lui
aujourd'hui
de là vous avez tenté autre chose vous
avez tenté la france insoumise
est-ce que là vous avez était davantage
satisfait ou pas du tout la question
la question est de savoir
et puis voilà pour défendre
qu'est ce que vous en concluez
aujourd'hui que les responsables
politiques sont hors sol qu'ils sont
malhonnêtes qu'est ce que vous leur
reprochez lors de tout mettre au cul
tente de l'argent à la finance et je
vais vous donner un exemple très simple
lui ligne la principale unis du
département elle appartient à payer
comme il y à des salariés qui ont des
mauvaises conditions de travail
déry à la fin de leur carrière des
cancers des cancers au team aux communes
aux alentours
il ya le risque de l'umih délocalisation
en 2025 en pologne
est ce que vous croyez que des élus
locaux des élus nationaux comme les
sénateurs ici présents vont y fier de
défendre les salariés les habitants en
sachant que des feuilles fines en faux
cuir très puissant en france et que
l'actionnaire et que les paris accélère
parlez nous de cette expérience au sein
des gilet jaune est ce que vous l'avez
vécue comme un nouveau souffle
démocratique vous y avez cru à nouveau
ce moment là c'est pas la question de
croire ou ne pas croire de lavelli on
prend un but de votre émission que je
souhaitais la révolution ou non ce que
je veux c'est que ceux qui ont besoin
d'être défendue socke ont besoin de
politiques de politiques qui sont en
capacité de changer les choses
ces personnes là les plus faibles elles
n'ont pas défendu alors baptiste touchon
est ce que vous croyez encore en la
démocratie la démocratie à la têtue et
en 2012
il y avait un choix à faire entre
françois hollande et par cauet on a
choisi françois hollande sur la base
d'un programme
françois hollande n'a pas appliqué ses
engagements c'est pas qu'il a tué la
gauche sait pas qui l'a tué le parti
social il a tué la démocratie
enfin un moment donné donc il faut que
ça s'arrête
sourire on s'engage sur des propositions
on les appuie et on respecte le suffrage
des électeurs français ce qui se passait
ses lecteurs il n'ya tout démocrate qui
plus est source nous avec des gens qu'on
fait campagne pour françois hollande
sont tous ceux qui n'ont pas forcément
été au parti socialiste mais qui ont
voté pour lui qu'ont cru qu'il y avait
un des changements qui était possible
d'entrer en direction des personnes les
plus défavorisées les plus grandes
difficultés à bari ces personnes là
aujourd'hui on a décidé de porter
plainte contre hollande on va faire
réagir jacques fernique on entend un
citoyen extrêmement déçus des promesses
qui n'ont semble-t-il pas été tenues et
un président qui aurait même tuer
lettres démocrate
il ya des mots des expressions fortes
dans l'ain dans la déception et la
colère rentrée qu'on sent effectivement
chez baptiste et c'est des choses
auxquelles nous faisions on n'est pas
étranger à cela les politiques nous si
je dirais les élus on a deux de
l'insatisfaction on a envie d'avoir des
résultats on a envie de voir le bout des
actes des politiques publiques et c'est
vrai que que que les citoyens sont
d'autant plus en colère lors je crois
pas que ça date seulement de 2012
voilà la crise démocratique la
difficulté particulièrement par une
société française à oxygéner la
démocratie à sortir de ce système et qui
fait qu'on a le sentiment que tout se
joue à l'élection présidentielle et que
c'est de cette sorte de contrat
présidentiel magique que sortirait
mécaniquement les politiques publiques
qui vont se déployer
c'est vrai quand je me rappelle en 2012
au moment des législatives
françois hollande était déjà élu on
était pour le deuxième tour dans un
contrat commun avec le parti socialiste
et j'ai défendu dans des réunions
publiques
je m'occupais de la partie éducation et
je me rappelle qu'à l'époque j'avais
j'avais peur que ce soit un exercice de
communication uniquement
on annonçait ce qui serait fait échéance
par échéances sur le front de la paix
l'éducation dont on sait que c'est un
enjeu majeur
un enjeu majeur de de l'égalité de
l'émancipation de bonne qualité
d'insertion d'orientation des jeunes et
des jeunes pour leur éviter la précarité
et bien j'avoue que très très vite
quand je me rappelle de ce que j'ai dit
en réunion publique quand j'ai vu
comment tout cela n'était que du vent
mais c'est notre modèle de démocratie
déformé par ce présidentialisme excessif
qui fonctionne d'ailleurs un peu à tous
les niveaux parce que au niveau local
communal on a aussi une forme de
présidentialisme cette verticalité de
cette verticalité qui fait qu'on a je
suis rennais je suis alsacien
je vois le des modèles qui sont
différents en europe en allemagne en
suisse
qui ont aussi des problèmes qui ont
aussi des difficultés qu'ont aussi des
citoyens qui sont mécontents mais qui
n'ont pas cette espèce de 2,2 sentiment
que tout se joue un coup l'élection
présidentielle tout le reste en découle
et qui fait qu'après on est dans la
colère dans le ressentiment dans
l'abondon dans l'amont baissent les bras
et les politiques ont le sentiment que
pour ceux qui sont aux manettes que ce
qu'ils disent ce qu'ils proposent au
moment électoral n'a guère de
conséquence sur ce qu'ils feront ensuite
et pourtant il y à d'autres élections
baptiste touchon par exemple est-ce que
vous allez saisir cette opportunité de
voter lors des départementales et
régionales qui ont lieu dans un mois
voilà j'ai entendu que celle interne su
faire ni donc je suis d'accord avec ce
qu'il dit a pas de souci voilà jeté en
face de moi ou jullion de l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on a un os il est vraiment
très important pour notre département
est celui en tant que sénateur est ce
qu'ils les feraient ci lui communique
les informations de concert improbable
du site b ça donne le département
qu'est ce qui est fait à regarder à ce
dossier là et éventuellement interpellé
l'état pour empêcher les délocalisations
et pour faire en sorte que cette
physique pour lui - et que les salariés
puissent conserver mais la santé et
profiter un petit peu de leur retraite
est ce que monsieur j'y suis d'autant
plus près que je dirais
fonctionnellement dans les
responsabilités que j'ai prise au sénat
j'y suis depuis le début octobre fait
partie de la mission d'information sur
les transports de marchandises je suis
pour le groupe écologiste en charge sur
la loi climat de tout le volet transport
et donc on a un véritable enjeu pour la
filière automobile de deux
transformations de mutation industrielle
il faut prendre le pas de la
décarbonation et je pèse et je suis pas
seul un pour qu'on ait un véritable
prise en compte du volet social
alors on veut qu'ils se permettent
que ça soit et on vous donne les
coordonnées de baptiste touchant juste
après et xavier iacovelli oui bonjour
monsieur touchons et moi je serai que
votre intervention m'interpelle
également et notamment sur la question
de la santé puisque moi je souhaite
affaires sociales et c'est vrai que sur
la santé des des salariés de psa et
aujourd'hui nous avons travaillé sur
notamment une une proposition de loi à
trans partisane et ça c'est aussi
important sur la question la pollution
des sols et donc justement comment est
ce que on accompagne les les habitants
suite à ces différentes pollution due à
l'industrialisation et à la question qui
nous occupe ce soir mais je sens la
démocratique
on voit des décrocheurs de la démocratie
alors il n'est peut-être pas encore tout
à fait baptiste touchon milan n'est pas
loin comment on ramène ses citoyens qui
sont écoeurés on peut le dire alors déjà
moi je voulais dire que j'estime que on
n'a pas tué la démocratie
on a peut-être tué des partis politiques
qui étaient là depuis des années moi
même je venais je viens du parti
socialiste je l'ait quitté en 2000 en
effectivement j'ai cru en 2012 à
l'arrivée de françois hollande avec un
certain nombre de promesses j'ai
accompagné jusqu'au bout le quinquennat
de françois hollande avec des déceptions
que j'ai tu que j'ai gardé parce que
effectivement comme j'étais élu du parti
socialiste je donnais mon opinion en
interne mais j'ai vite et de l'exprimer
en externe jusqu'au bout on a on ne peut
plus rudes un moment soutenir un parti
politique qui ne l'incarné plus le
progrès que moi j'attendais que sur
lequel je m'étais engagé dans cette
formation était un déçu vous êtes donc
j'ai été aussi déçu mais j'ai été un
déçu de l'appareil j'ai pas été un déçu
de la démocratie et c'est ça que je
voulais dire à baptiste touchon c'est
que je pense effectivement que il y à
une nécessité de réinventer notre modèle
partisans notre modèle démocratique
n'est pas la démocratie
si aujourd'hui on vous pose la question
de savoir si vous pouvez voter
si vous allez à voter au mois de juin
sur les élections départementales ou
régionales c'est justement parce que
nous sommes en démocratie et donc il
faut que les citoyens il faut que nous
tous en tant que citoyens
on se saisissent de cette chance que
nous avons de pouvoir exprimer et de
choisir nos représentants
et ça c'est pour ça que je voulais vous
dire que encore une fois la démocratie
n'est pas morte mais il faut réinventer
certainement la façon de faire la
politique alors donné
audry on se tourne vers vous vous êtes
prêté au jeu démocratique puisque vous
avez participé à cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat expérience
enrichissante dites vous mais vous en
ressortez déçu vous aussi pourquoi
bonjour à tous nos obligations
déçu par ce qu'on appelle tas de dalles
et les sénateurs les députés le
législatif aujourd'hui m appeler à la
démocratie participative
mais si si vous ne pas devenir vous nous
a demandé notre opinion notre réflexion
et que à la sortie vous en tenez pas
compte
il doit pas en coiffe et participatif
donc c est surtout là dessus où on est
de suite passé lors de la convention
officielle pour le climat on prend une
première claque comme d'un porte de
notre lettre de mission qui est d'être
comment réduire les gaz à effet de serre
donc on prend une première plaque sur
l'état du climat mais ensuite durant
cette convention citoyenne mois où j'ai
pris ce deuxième place et c'est sur la
démocratique ont conduit actuellement
j'ai plus l'impression qu'on est en
oligarchie qu'en démocratie et après le
le pompon la cerise sur le gâteau c'est
qu'on nous parle de démocratie
participative éclatant en on le voit
d'un côté le climat où on prend très peu
content de de la vie des citoyens
alors au delà du au delà du résultat qui
vous déçoit on l'a entendu cet exercice
en lui même de la consultation citoyenne
est ce que vous avez trouvé que ça
fonctionnait bien vous vous êtes senti
quand même écouter vous avez vu des
échanges où vous avez senti que tout
était joué d'avancé
non on aaron on a joué on a il est
certain que quand on est arrivé au
départ dans un autre champ de notre
troisième chambre quelques heures ont
fait poser la question pourquoi nous
notamment moi je suis suicider déclaré
dans le marais des quartiers athlètes en
chine me suis posé la question de savoir
qu'est ce que je faisais là et on nous a
sorti j'ai vu je faisais partie un peu
de ce mouvement gilet jaune
on nous a sorti de la rue pour venir
dans notre opinion tout ça mais le ca la
fin le résultat quand qu'on a fait le
travail au départ on n'a rien demandé on
nous demande de participer mois
trente ans que j'allais plus aux urnes
parce que je ne croyais plus tôt
politique je ne croyais plus de
démocratie
mais aujourd'hui j'ai repris une valeur
grâce à la convention citoyenne j'ai
repris légitimité de citoyens et je me
dis qu'il est important d'aller de
retourner aux urnes mais quand on voit
le résultat qui a été fait avec la
commencer citoyenne xavier iacovelli oui
moi déjà je voulais saluer tous ceux qui
se sont engagés dans cette convention
citoyenne parce que moi je vous cache
pas que au départ quand on a annoncé la
convention citoyenne aussi bon ça sera
un tirage au sort mais de façade
en fin de compte c'est les gens qui
auront postulé pourquoi vous avez dit ça
parce que je vais vous même pas
confiance dont je suis du bon ça allait
fonctionner j'avais pas regardé et
spécifiquement la méthodologie mais je
ne croyais pas forcément au tirage au
sort et en fin de compte j'ai eu
quelqu'un dans ma circonscription à
nanterre mélanie blancheteau qui
maintenant a décidé de s'engager
politiquement suite à cette convention
qui n'était pas du tout engagé
politiquement et donc j'ai vu
effectivement que c'était un vrai tirage
au sort et monsieur vous venez de le
confirmer avec des citoyens qui
n'étaient pas engagés politiquement qui
n'étaient pas engagés forcément dans des
associations de climatique ou de défense
de l'environnement ont préféré voir le
verre à moitié plein c'est finalement ce
sont des gens qui n'étaient pas engagés
qu'ils le deviennent qu'il devienne
parce cette cette façon inédite de
consulter la population mais après
moscou
oui mais c'est ça que je voulais
répondre c'est que je peux comprendre
que quand on s'engage dans dans une
convention dans une préparation qu'on a
un projet on a envie que toutes nos
propositions soient reprises et ça je le
comprends parce que moi même et enfin on
a on a tous fait des élections
lorsqu'on fait un projet on envie de
gagner ces élections pour mettre en
oeuvre notre projet on force est de
constater que là effectivement toutes
les propositions n'ont pas été reprises
mais il ya quand même 20 % de ces
propositions qui était d'engins dans le
projet de loi de finances 10 % qui sont
d'un point de vue réglementaire dont il
qu'ils ne viendront jamais dans la loi
parce qu'elles sont mis dans dans le
réglementaire et il ya 70 propositions
sur 146 qui ont été retenus et donc bien
sûr qu'on pourra dire ce n'est jamais
assez mais enfin je veux dire vous
avait fait progresser aussi la question
grâce à votre participation et moi c'est
ça que j'ai envie de relever dans cette
cette initiative inédite si je crois que
de nabot driver réagir même les les 70
ont été retenus les textes est modique
et on le voit pas on parle du transport
thaler on le voit sur le malus auto on
parlait de 1800 kg on est retombé à on
est retombé à 1400 kg si bien tu as
beaucoup moins d'impact on parlait de
des vols des vols aériens ont parlé d'un
transfert via le via les corbières pour
point qu'on durée de quatre heures la
pâte à 2h30 sa touche très peu de lignes
dit il ya un manque quelque chose de
fait c'est bien et bien quelque chose a
été faite puisque rien n'avait été fait
depuis ce panneau central de deux
actions très peu ou très peu de choses
avaient été faites
la maison brûle et nous regardons à côté
quelque chose a été faite et bien mais
qu'est ce qu'un jour on aura un
politicien assez courageux pour aller
jusqu'au bout des idées citoyennes juste
l'excusé mois mais la politique c'est
aussi arbitré parfois et c'est normal
qu'au bout d'une fine et le politique en
ayant une vision globale de la situation
puisse arbitrer ski réalisable et ce qui
me les - ou ce qui peut le faire
peut-être en plusieurs étapes et donc
encore une fois moi je vois plutôt le
verre à moitié plein plutôt qu'à moitié
vide
jacques fernique trois choses sur la
convention citoyenne moi j'ai toujours
cru c'est mon engagement à la fois de
pédagogue de militants associatifs
politiques de profond si j'ai toujours
cru en l'intérêt de de la participation
citoyenne
pour moi c'est pas un gadget c'est une
nécessité surtout non je dis regarde
dans l'action locale la démocratie de
proximité si on la fait pas fonctionner
avec les citoyens on se plante donc
cette méta salué cette méthode je la
salue je la salue c'est quelque chose
effectivement dont je voyais un terrain
je savais que ça serait pas évident que
ce ne serait pas facile
et donc c'est bien je crois que la
déception qu'on a ou si je pense qu'elle
va nous apprendre des choses et qu'elle
va permettre d'avancer pour qu'on arrête
de lui parce que il a dit on a joué le
jeu mais faut pas jouer avec eux faut
pas jouer avec eux il ya eu des
déclarations solennelles qu'on était
fait personne n'a obligé le président a
trois fois solennellement publiquement
de dire qu'il y aurait trois jokers
uniquement trois jokers c'était on se
rappelle la vitesse limitée sur
autoroute c'était la taxe de 4 % sur les
dividendes et c'était un joker
d'ailleurs qu'il n'a pas utilisé
finalement le préambule de la
constitution par référendum
personne n'avait oblige à dire ça et que
tout le reste ça serait sans filtre
alors sans filtre moi j'ai tout de suite
compris comme parlementaire qui avait
une ambiguïté
ça signifiait pas qu'on allait
l'appliquer dans les politiques
publiques automatiquement sans fil ça
signifiait qu'on allait le transmettre
sans filtre ou à la machine
parlementaire pour qu'elle le travail
mais pour qu'elle le travail en échange
là dessus j'ai regretté mois que nos
sénateurs et c'est ccc du c7 la
responsabilité du sénat de la majorité
du sénat
on n'est pas eu l'occasion de pouvoir
échanger comme l'ont fait les députés
d'aiguebelle défilèrent avait pas ce que
la majorité est là elle elle a refusé
qu'on n'ait pas eu l'occasion de
dialoguer avec les lait conventionnel
citoyens de la convention et puis quand
même une chose sa troisième chose c'est
pour vous qu'on collectionne weeds
je veux bien mais il y avait un cahier
des charges ce cahier des charges c'est
dans la justice sociale baissé de 40%
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
la france en 2030 sur la base de celle
de 90 et la coface qu'est ce que vous
voulez avec les propositions convention
citoyenne je veux bien mais quel est
l'impact mesuré de ce qu'on a dans la
loi qui nous est proposé aujourd'hui ça
en fait à peine au mieux la moitié du
chemin c'est à dire mais vous allez sur
le fond pardonner mais sur la méthode ce
soir et sur cette question
direct des charges démocratie absolument
mais n'allons pas sur le fond alexandre
ngogo avons re bonsoir à vous vous ne
voulez plus du tout entendre parler de
ce qu'on appelle le front républicain
notamment en cas de ce duel
emmanuel macron marine le pen qui semble
être prévue par les par les sondages en
2022 c'est bien ça oui alors tout
d'abord je me mets en être et de citer
un auteur qui s'appelle bernanos et
puisque c'est le de l'émission que la
démocratie tu es de la langue française
pour moi c'est quelque chose de très
près avec toujours aujourd'hui dans la
mesure où on utilise ce mot de
démocratie pour absolument tout et rien
moi j'aimerais un jour quand on met une
définition relativement claires ou parce
que la démocratie est là c'est quoi
c'est historiquement dans l'ain dans les
temps antiques c'est la boule et on
appelait ça la boulaye dans l'antiquité
grecque c'était le boulanger le forgeron
qui venait et qui participait à la vie
la démocratie c'est le petit prenait
directement les décisions vont
évidemment aujourd'hui ça vous coupe
évolué on peut tendre vers cette idée
participation comme on l'a vu comme vous
en parliez messieurs voilà comment c'est
mais moi je dirais je gégé est en cours
j'ai je connais mon histoire de mon pays
et je connais les caractéristiques de la
démocratie connaît les caractéristiques
de l' inverse ce que l'on appelle la
dictature
les caractéristiques de la démocratie
c'est la masse faisons et c'est surtout
l'impact que peut avoir le citoyen sur
la vie la vie de la cité politique a
cité un peu de bézy mélodieux et je veux
dire parce qu'aujourd'hui dans une
société où ce qui s'apparente à la la
participation citoyenne
quant aux dans le système c'est
également un système bicaméral comme
andy est aujourd'hui parmi des noix en
aidant
zambie où ça fait déjà au moins deux ans
que notre président des riches a été
créé c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait plus
rien contient un projet de loi qu'on
veut passer à l'assemblée puis au sénat
il ya cela fait parlement dès
aujourd'hui si simplement président
d'ard 9,3 à signer si les statuts masse
menacent on va dire aujourd'hui mois
dont le pouvoir qu'a le président par
rapport d'accord régime trop
présidentiel xavier covelli moi je suis
pas complètement en désaccord avec ce
que vous venez de dire
alors déjà je pense que tous les hommes
politiques ne sont pas des énarques ou
des hauts fonctionnaires
moi je suis fils d'ouvrier j'ai grandi
dans une cité et c'est par une action de
terrain que j'ai que je suis devenu
d'abord élu local
je suis toujours puis sénateur mais pour
revenir sur sur la la la constitution
moi je pense effectivement qu'il faut
faire évoluer une constitution il faut
faire évoluer nos constitutions sur la
question du 49 3 mois j'ai toujours été
opposé aux 49 3 je pense que en tant que
social démocrate je suis pour le le
trouver des compromis d'une négociation
plutôt que de ne pas le passage en force
donc à titre personnel je suis après ce
n'est pas constitutionnelle mais sur la
question du quinquennat moi je pense
qu'il ya une question sur le quinquennat
liés et ça c'est la version du
calendrier de jospin je pense que lier
les législatives au commença au
président de la république à l'élection
présidentielle ça complètement dénaturé
le donateur un régime trop président
cette verticalité qui vient donc moi et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que au sénat on
est beaucoup plus libre que l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'on ne dépend pas
directement de l'élection présidentielle
après sur la question de la
participation citoyenne
pour en revenir quand même à st vous
savez moi quand j'ai été élu sénateur en
j'ai décidé de ne pas être un sénateur
de palais c'est à dire d'être présent
sur des textes sur lesquels je
travaillais mais restait un ancrage
territorial sur le terrain et j'ai aussi
créé le conseil sénatoriales pour
associer à la fois les élus mais aussi
les citoyens en amont des textes de lois
pour deux mandats
ravie et les tester sur les différentes
avancées qu'on pourrait avoir sur les
textes à ce que je pense que c'est
important
et aujourd'hui il ya plein d'outils qui
sont mis en place à destination des
citoyens à destination des
parlementaires je pense notamment à
l'application nos lois dont je suis
premier sénateur à être sur cette
application il ya des éléments
aujourd'hui qui nous permette d'avoir ce
lien direct avec la population ça vous
rassure un peu avec sandrine gogo quand
vous entendez ce ses discours venant
d'un parlementaire alors ça me rassure
ni l'ange suis content que tu t'y
d'aider des gens qui se tasse peut faire
des de pousser un peu les choses pour
revenir à une forme de démocratie comme
on dit mais malheureusement ça fait des
années des années des années qu'on
entend toujours sur un type de discours
avec des des tentatives de petits pas de
choses comme ça aujourd'hui j'écoute est
encore à la radio hier un débat pour
mort pour l'élection régionale de la
région qu'est l'occitanie on écoute tous
les candidats alors il ya un débat ya un
débat et les oui mais par rapport à
cette problématique là la présidente
sortante de la région d'y aller ça on ne
peut rien faire c'est le président qui
décide on n'a pas la compétence
les hôpitaux qui était je suis fait deux
ans qu'on est connaît ni dans une danse
je parle d'utiliser le terme est dans
une crise est insupportable parce que
soi-disant les hôpitaux sont saturés
on a encore une fois un gouvernement
venant qui ne fait rien pour augmenter
les capacités hospitalières
moi je salue au japon jal au japon
récemment on a tendance à dire que la
france est une très grande puissance
mondiale le japon
je veux dire en sont à des années
lumières du système hospitalier qu'est
le nôtre lan wan traite de temps on va
laisser réagir jacques fernique on
entend trop de verrous trop de
verticalité un problème les choses
bloqué on le voit bien avec la crise de
la pandémie qui a déferlé sur nous
depuis depuis plus d'un an
il faut de la réactivité il faut de
l'adaptation il ya un niveau dont on n'a
pas parlé aujourd'hui la tasse après
midi c c'est le niveau le niveau
européen jeudi deux pour que la
démocratie prenne son essor fonctionne
pour qu'on est prise les citoyens
aussi le débat politique au niveau
européen parce que c'est là que se joue
à toute une série de grandes décisions
sur le climat sur les transitions à
mener mais ça ça risque de rebuter
encore plus les citoyens avec et ce soir
les rues menant au parlement
si on dit aux citoyens tout se joue au
plan national on leur ment on leur donne
quelque chose de ne manquer si on leur
fait croire que tout se joue au niveau
communal et qu'en tant que maire on
pourra agir et alors que l'essentiel de
l'opérationnel c'est l'intercommunalité
si dans une élection au départemental un
coin ce que quelqu'un qui aspire à
devenir conseiller départemental leur
explique qui va résoudre les problèmes
de sécurité etc
il le raconte des bêtises il faut une
bonne articulation il faut pas mentir
aux citoyens et il faut que la
démocratie elles tiennent les deux bouts
moi j'étais très heureux d'entamer leur
venoix qui disait que la convention
citoyenne lui a redonné une certaine de
légitimité la refais citoyens et la
science is a le risque contre ce excède
crise de la démocratie cette
déstructuration de la citoyenneté
elle joue aussi des formes pas non plus
les élus le protestataire que
l'individualisme que les gens qui
croient que la participation citoyenne
c'est défendre des intérêts particuliers
il faut réussir à retrouver ensemble
sens de la citoyenneté s'est pas
seulement attirée dans un parti
politique c'est aussi participer et
quand on est dans une association locale
quand on est dans une convention
similaire où on est au fait de la
politique indirectement et donc moi
j'invite vraiment tout ce même ne pas
aller dans les partis politiques mais
investissez vous pour votre sang la vie
de la cité on va venir justement c'est
déjà la fin de cette première partie
merci à tous d'y avoir participé merci
d'avoir participé à cet échange on va
maintenant donner la parole à des
citoyens qui ont décidé de faire de la
politique mais sow les politiques sans
les partis en dehors des structures
traditionnelles leurs méthodes sont un
peu moins orthodoxes mais leur
engagement est tout aussi fort on va les
accueillir dans un instant je propose
d'abord de découvrir de nouvelles images
celle d'une citoyenne pour qui les
messages passent
mieux par les réseaux sociaux c'est sa
façon à elle de s'engager via les
réseaux sociaux des personnes qui sont
considérés comme n'étant personnes
peuvent en fait du jour au lendemain
rassembler sur une même page s'exprimer
tout ensemble se sentir soutenu et
surtout avoir un réel poids et donc
grâce à ces pages instagram j'ai pu
mener plusieurs gros combats qui ont
fait je dois dire pas mal de bruit sur
la sphère transport qui en fait toujours
suivant les mêmes dynamiques de silence
et de bas de viol et d'agression
sexuelle en masse malheureusement permis
de mettre à jour le fait qu a vu nombre
de violences sexuelles dans des yeux
paix à travers la france
moi j'entends à ce moment là parce que
forcément sur instagram n'y a pas de
tabou on peut sortir à peu près ce qu'on
veut surtout que moi je suis sage une
suppose une association je ne suis pas
un média du coup je m'appuie uniquement
sur les témoignages que je reçois et
donc ça a été chose aisée pour moi les
deux fois que de faire sortir ça et de
le faire sortir jusque dans les médias
dans les jt en une des grands journaux
est évidemment dans les sphères
politique et je suis très contente de
faire partie de cette nouvelle vague
d'activisme qui arrive à changer les
choses juste à la force du doigt et on
vous retrouve dans dialogue citoyen
anatomy of bienvenue à vous vous avez
donc 26 ans vous habitez entre bruxelles
paris et le sud de la france vous est ce
qu'on appelle donc une influence sur les
réseaux sociaux une militante féministe
vous vous sentez donc beaucoup plus
libre que les politiques aucun frein
aucune limite sur les réseaux et ça
c'est votre clé avoue véronique caillard
est également avec nous bien venu vous
avez 65 ans vous habitez noisy-le-sec en
seine-saint-denis vous étiez psycho
psychologue
vous êtes une femme engagée depuis
toujours en 2018 la démission nicolas
hulot est pour vous un électrochoc et
vous décidez alors de franchir un
nouveau cap dans votre militantisme et
vous nous direz comment jérôme py mois
et également avec nous bien venu vous
avez 51 ans vous avez vécu des
expériences douloureuses en tant que
livreur à vélo pour les plateformes mais
plutôt que de prendre la voie syndicale
traditionnelle qui ne vous représentez
pas apparemment
vous avez créé un collectif indépendant
vous nous direz ce que vous reprochez
d'ailleurs au syndicat et pourquoi vous
avez pris ce chemin un peu différent
avec vous pour échanger ce soir agnès
canayer bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice de
la seine maritime apparenté au groupe et
l'air et secrétaire de la commission des
lois
pierre laurent bienvenue à vous vous
êtes sénateur communiste de paris vice
président du sénat vice président de la
commission des affaires européennes et
de la commission des affaires étrangères
anna tour madoff vous l'action vous
l'amenez donc sur les réseaux sociaux et
vous vous y sentez plus libre que si
vous vous lanciez en politique
oui tout à fait parce que en fait ce qui
va se passer sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est que on n'a pas de on n'a pas de
réel cale en tout cas pour les quelques
10 ont influencé féministes qui ne sont
pas dans des associations
si un beau jour on reçoit par exemple en
témoignage où il nous arrive quelque
chose de particulier ou en tout cas on a
connaissance d'une situation on peut
sans aucun frein ni les lignes 10 ont
décidé va de de lancer une action
massive en utilisant les ressorts dieu
je relis citoyens ça veut dire que vous
avez l'impression finalement de
vulgariser de démocratiser votre cause
de l'élargir un public plus important
oui oui tout à fait parce que sur
instagram c'est vrai qu'on peut vraiment
quel logiciel sur instagram et les
autres réseaux sociaux c'est un peu la
même chose j'ai l'opportunité grâce à g
de pouvoir aller toucher en fait des
personnes qui ne sont pas de base un
dessert politiques qui ne sont pas dans
des fermes hésitant ce qu'ils sont dix
romans peut-être très vulgairement des
prochaines et qui en cas de fraude mais
ce mouvement par l'interminable de
contenu extrêmement opaque finalement
vont avoir accès en prêtent à cette
pensée qui est qui est très politique et
très engagé et est ce que vous sentez
que c'est vraiment efficace c'est à dire
est ce que vous sentez que vous
sensibiliser en profondeur des gens à la
cause féministe puisque c'est celle que
vous défendez sur les réseaux sociaux ou
quelque chose d'un peu instantanée avec
des réactions dans l'immédiat peut être
très positif mais qui ne débouchent sur
rien derrière
r2 chose là-dessus effectivement il ya
tout ce qu'on a payé toutes les
personnes il faut qu mettre un petit
carré noir pour montrer qu'ils étaient
hyper consciente des enjeux puis qu'on
n'a plus jamais vu parler dans le
curatif
bon c'était chet mais la deuxième chose
c'est que apport de 2 finalement de
marteler en fait des messages
c'est à dire que par exemple chez une
page se sont fait une page de même donc
c'était contenu humoristique donc on
n'est pas eu très loin dans le propos un
peu on peut en jargon et c est ce qui se
passe c'est que les gens like les gens
identifiés leur demi les gens vont le
partager dans leur story est en fait ça
fait qu'il ya autant de tares fun qui ne
s'arrête pas au féminisme qui voit pas
et qui voient ça au quotidien
donc en fait qui est extrêmement
intéressant est que en fait que le
travail finit par un primé en fait les
messages et même des personnes qui font
un peu réfractaires finalement qui sont
pas forcément d'accord avec moi que je
vais raconter ou qui trouve même que le
féminisme n'a aucune légitimité en 2021
et bah ça va quand même en fait imprimer
patron de parler en permanence donc du
coup par exemple sur le harcèlement de
rue les bons savoir que si ceux ci ne
sait pas par rapport au consentement
idées les bars des choses et je crois
que ça fonctionne dans la mesure où par
exemple beaucoup d'hommes ont maintenant
[Musique]
là c'est nouveau un atout majeur
pourquoi ne pas le faire au sein d'une
association ou même au sein d'un parti
politique pourquoi ne pas prendre cette
voie là être que comme je disais la gêne
liberté qui est non celle de bad
commandes est de pouvoir lancer en fait
des vagues de témoignages par exemple
comme c'était le cas avec leurs serveurs
ou à la culture sport donc d affaires
contre le beurre et contre tiësto donc à
chaque fois dès le départ de violences
sexuelles de textes sécurité de vous
combler il est dès lors une association
dans un parti il y aurait quand même des
comités qui devrait afficher avec moi si
voilà il aurait une temporalité très
différentes voilà j'espère vraiment de
l'instantanéité des réseaux sociaux et
delattre aux pensions que ça peut avoir
un très rapidement leur fait la presse
et des grosses séquences négative qui
met la pression
pierre laurent sent qu'il ya une vraie
demande d'indépendance et qui semble
passer par les réseaux sociaux et le
parti politique ou où les autres
structures sont ressentis comme un
enfermement
oui c'est ce qu'on dit mais moi je ne
suis pas du tout je moi je suis très
satisfait que des gens sous les formes
les plus diverses et est comme ça vient
des dix s'empare de deux questions aussi
importantes son nom par le militantisme
citoyen c'est pour moi c'est le moteur
dans la politique de toute façon donc
évidemment que des gens prennent
l'initiative individuellement ou parfois
en groupe d'ailleurs d'utiliser les
réseaux sociaux et d'ailleurs moi qui
suis un militant est maintenant un élu
j'utilise aussi beaucoup les réseaux
sociaux et ça me donne l'occasion de
parler à beaucoup de gens auxquels
probablement j'aurais difficilement du
mal à parler autrement
donc moi ça se sache je trouve ça je
trouve ça très bien et on sait par
exemple que sur les violences faites aux
femmes
ça a été un moteur puissant de
libération de la parole
ça fait bouger les choses ça continue de
les faire bouger et tant mieux après
évidemment moi j'ai ajouté à ça parce
que moi j'ai commencé comme ça aussi un
don au lycée il ya très très longtemps
quand je mettais mon lycée en grève pour
libérer angela davis qui était militante
noire américaine qui était en prison je
faisais la même chose
à l'époque il y avait pas les réseaux
sociaux mais bon donc on a tous on sait
tous engagés à un moment donné de
manière bon c'est vrai que moi j'ai
ajouté à ça le besoin d'eux
nous donner de les filtres à seulement
un cadre mais aussi un espace de
discussion collective parce que de tous
ces sujets de toutes ces mobilisations
de tous ces investissements il faut
essayer un moment donné de forge est
aussi un point de vue qui puisse devenir
un point de vue qui voilà qu'ils soient
qui l'emportent largement qui est
l'adhésion de beaucoup de gens parce que
c'est aussi comme ça qu'on fait bouger
la société
donc moi j'ai je vois pas de
contradiction en fait entre c'est la
multiplicité de ses engagements citoyens
et le fait de s'organiser
voilà donc la force à cinq ans qu'on
entend quand même dans le discours d'un
atout majeur un escalier ces cas une
forme de lourdeur dans les structures
traditionnelles les partis politiques
notamment mais pas seulement avec une
temporalité qui n'est pas la même que
celle des réseaux sociaux est ce que
c'est ça veut dire que les parties
doivent évoluer un peu se calquer sur
ces réseaux sociaux qui sont plus dans
l'instantanéité ou surtout pas
certainement mais je pense qu'il n'y a
pas une opposition entre la vie des
réseaux sociaux et l'alertent par les
réseaux sociaux et le fait de porter des
sujets et d'alerté en utilisant les
techniques des réseaux sociaux et qui
comme le dit justement donc la pierre
laurent sont des techniques que nous
utilisons nous aussi au quotidien dans
l'attraction publique et politique et la
vie des partis politiques qui étaient
vraiment indépendante
est ce que vous sentez que parfois vous
êtes vous êtes empêché par des strates
qui vous dépasse qui font partie de la
structure dans laquelle vous êtes mais
l'arbre est un peu particulier puisque
je ne suis plus dans mon parti donc je
suis sorti de mon parti politique donc
je n'étais pas dans la ligne je n'avais
pas
mes idées n'étaient pas forcément porté
au niveau de mon parti politique donc je
ne suis plus dans mon parti politique
il n'empêche que ça me permet aussi de
pauvres je continue à porter des actions
politiques en étant engagés et en ayant
un mandat de représentation
néanmoins c'est vrai que cet engagement
il vient au départ d'une volonté d'agir
et de faire avancer les choses
donc il suffit pas assez important
évidemment de pouvoir déjà soulevé des
problèmes d'alertés sur des problèmes de
fédérer autour des problèmes et tout
l'intérêt des réseaux sociaux
et comme le dit à madame qui permet
d'avoir une audience large aujourd'hui
une efficacité réelle parce que ça va
très vite c'est très puissant et ça va
très loin
néanmoins après il faut le transférer
transformées en actions publiques en
action politique
et là on a besoin d'un cadre d'une
structure et je crois que c'est le rôle
des partis politiques elle est peut-être
là la limite des réseaux sociaux anatomy
of est ce que vous y voyez une
complémentarité entre réseaux sociaux et
structures officielles type partis
politiques où vous dites non finalement
vous êtes plus efficace que les partis
n'ont pu avoir une marge de manoeuvre
qui est énorme en fait vraiment pas je
pense le point important à reconnaître
dans médailles dans mon activité
moi le but est clairement de lancer des
alertes et de faire émerger en fait des
choses après les partis politiques
françaises et ou non bon moi c'est vrai
qu'à chaque fois il ya eu des déceptions
parce que les partis politiques s'en
saisit le gouvernement s'empresse d'y
être un peu d effets d annonce mais
c'est aussi dû à des agendas politiques
qui sont tout le temps et par rapide et
sur la question en plus de l'égalité
hommes femmes
il a malheureusement de nouvelles
d'affaires chaque semaine presque mais
je ne crois pas moins tout comme mon
propos n'est pas n'est absolument pas
contre la structure politique en
elle-même où les élus est d'arras et
c'est pas ça le le but et je pense qu'on
peut on peut travailler en harmonie avec
en tout cas les personnes qui sont de
bonne volonté de bonne foi on se rend
compte très vite qu'en fait pour juste
récupérer après que ce qui est
intéressant dans le fait prof qui me
contente de pas être élu ne pas être
affiliés et qu'en dit qu'on fait minutes
que je vais amener images ne sont pas
partis qui c'est y pas tueur et des
partis kurdes à notre parti qui
travaillent avec moi mais qui ne saurait
pas le dire ne pourrait pas le dire
parce que elle pleurait pas votre parti
écureuils d'allégeance différents tels
que parent on connaît un peu
malheureusement fait des guerres de
pouvoir auquel en anglais de traiter le
un peu le flanc est arrivé au dessus
d'un milieu militant évidemment personne
est épargné mais mais voilà je pense que
c'est une réelle liberté on est un peu
des électrons libres en tant qu' en tant
que militant en tant qu'activiste un peu
visibles sur les réseaux qui les élus
doivent essayer de collaborer au maximum
alors véronique caillard je vais me
tourner vers vous maintenant le
militantisme l'engagement écologiste ça
a toujours fait partie de vous mais vous
êtes vraiment passer à l'action après la
démission de nicolas hulot qui je le
disais était une forme d'électrochoc 1
c'est ça et bien pas que nicolas hulot a
démissionné ça m'a fait vraiment un choc
et je me suis dit maintenant que l'état
nous à nous les les personnes les
citoyens de remonter nos manches et 2 et
de passer à l'action par rapport à
l'urgence climatique
moi je suis une citoyenne une sandale
suffisamment informé les informations ne
parviennent
et devant l'urgence il me semblait
important d'agir
donc j'ai commencé plus tôt au départ
par suivre les marches pour le climat
notamment avec alternatiba et puis très
rapidement je j'ai participé à des
actions concrètes
par exemple le blocage de la défense par
on était à peu près 2000
activis nous avons bloqué quatre tours
edf total la société générale et de
l'univers de la transition écologique et
puis nous j'ai aussi participé à des
déblocages j'ai été enchaînés devant les
entrepôts amazon
tout ça pour montrer l'importance d'agir
pour tout dire je me sens une
responsabilité morale si vous voulez
vis-à-vis des jeunes qui s'engagent et
je ne puis que maintenant j'ai du temps
devant moi parce que je suis retraité
mais j'ai envie de consacrer vraiment
mal dit à soutenir le mouvement parfait
que le gouvernement ne ne va pas ne
passeras ne suivent pas tout à fait
d'eux les engagements qu'il a pris
notamment les désengagements de paris et
puis là par rapport à la pauvre enfant
citoyenne pour le climat comme nous
l'avons vu tout à l'heure pour en rester
sur la méthode véronique ailleurs est ce
que ça veut dire que pour vous
aujourd'hui pour faire bouger les lignes
pour faire avancer les choses il n'y a
plus que la force l'illégalité la
désobéissance civile c'est comme cela
qu'il faut expliquer les choses n'ont
fait en parallèle mais c'est très
important par je prendrai un autre
exemple quand françois hollande a été
élu il avait à il avait beaucoup de
pouvoir quitte à dire qu'il avait à la
fois les régions le le sénat le
palatinat mais la chambre des députés et
et malheureusement il n'en est pas
suffisamment les choses et peut-être que
nous n'avons pas nous les citoyens
étaient suffisamment derrière vie pour
soutenir et je pense que les actions
comme ça l'activisme j'ai aussi pour
poser un prix des larmes lanceurs
d'alerté et mettre une pression pour que
les gouvernants à gifles vraiment dans
le sens là bon pour qu'ils complètent et
l'urgence climatique
agnès canayer ce qu'on entend c'est que
donc finalement mettre un bulletin dans
l'urne aujourd'hui ne semble plus
suffire en tout cas aux yeux de madame
et aux yeux de beaucoup d'autres qui
mènent et qui n'hésitent plus à franchir
la ligne rouge la ligne de la légalité
aussi oui alors ce que madame appel
l'activisme on voit c'est un engagement
personnel fort qui effectivement ne peut
aller au delà des limites de ce qui est
autorisé
c'est un moyen alors nous dit elle de
tirer des sonnettes d'alarmé de ce côté
là où moi je ne peux pas cautionner de
comportements qui sont ils dans le
contredire évidemment je vous interpelle
bien évidemment je pense que c'est
important cette pression citoyenne
d'ailleurs elle est importante et elle
faisait partie autrefois du militantisme
quand on est et on se mobilise et on
s'est mobilisé tous pour défendre des
causes à plusieurs titres
aujourd'hui on voit que cette cet
engagement il prend parfois des formes
beaucoup plus radicale c'est vrai que ça
peut poser question sur les finalités
néanmoins moi je reste persuadé que
derrière il faut peut-être contesté mais
il faut aussi s'engager avec un projet
pour faire avancer les choses parce que
je trouve ça très bien d'alerté mais
derrière pour quel projet pour quelles
actions et comment on fait en sorte que
ça avance plus vite
pourquoi ne pas aller militer au sein
d'une association ou d'un parti
politique donc
veronica iard et bien parce que les
partis politiques ont tout à fait leur
place mais pour moi ce n'est pas
suffisant les dernières décennies nous
ont montré à là on est vraiment passés à
une urgente et
et s'il n'y avait pas cette pression de
la population
je ne suis pas sûr que les choses
aillent au physique afin qu'elles n'ont
pour l'instant ne vont pas du tout à
fait dit mais il me semble que s'il ya
des pizzas vente et c'est surtout parce
que il y à la pression de la population
derrière qui est là pour inciter
encourager il n'aime plus pour pour
faire avancer les choses
et alors non mais ça a toujours enfin
moi je je je moi j'encourage va
continuer à s'investir de cette manière
parce qu'en fait ça a toujours avancé
comme ça toutes les grandes causes ont
nécessité des mobilisations citoyennes
très importante et même quand il y avait
au gouvernement au temps du front
populaire des gouvernements de gauche
qui ont fait des choses mais il y avait
en même temps des très grandes
mobilisations parce qu'il faut appuyer
faut pousser mais oui mais oui moi je
continue de faire les deux
s'il faut aller demain dans mon quartier
empêcher une expulsion locative parce
que je la trouve scandaleuse
moi je vais aller avec les locataires
empêcher cette expulsion locative ça
m'arrivait avant que je sois
parlementaire et ça continue de
m'arriver aujourd'hui je prends cet
exemple là mais ça pourrait être
l'occupation des tours à la défense dont
parle madame monfils enfin un de mes
fils y était donc moi j'ai aucun
problème avec avec tout ça donc je pense
que icc comme comme dit madame c'est
même nécessaire
ces voix là où on voit bien que dans les
mots mais regardez ce qui se passe on
peut prendre des exemples internationaux
je pense que ça intéressera madame parce
que si on s'intéresse à la cause
écologique le monde entier nous
intéresse en ce moment là au chili sont
en train de changer la constitution à ça
faisait des décennies qu'il avait une
constitution héritée pinochet il
n'arrivait pas la changer
il y avait des changements de
gouvernement même de gauche et puis il
avait toujours la même constitution il a
fallu un énorme mouvement citoyen qui
vient de déboucher sur l'élection d'une
assemblée constituante complètement
nouvelle et dans cette assemblée
constituante
il ya plein de citoyens qui se sont
engagés l'année dernière et qui
voilà où sont entrées dans la vie
politique comme ça et moi je suis dans
un parti où il ya énormément de gens qui
viennent à l'action politique et au
militantisme politique parce qu'avant
ils ont été dans des mouvements
associatifs ils ont été syndicaliste ils
se sont engagés sur la cause écologique
etc et juliette à un mot qui a dit
madame qui est très important et qui
explique aussi des choses en ce moment
c'est l'urgence parce que il ya des
choses qui deviennent insupportables
on voit bien sûr par exemple l'écologie
tout le monde dit qui va bien et qui va
être trop tard ou qu'il est peut-être
même déjà trop tard et c'est vrai que
face à cette urgence la meilleure aussi
les urgences sociales qui rompt des
choses insupportables
effectivement et alors que ça fait un
moment déjà que beaucoup de gens tirent
la sonnette d'alarmé
le fait que ça n'avance pas et que ça
continue bloqués ça devient
insupportable a beaucoup de gens et pas
juste des petites minorités mais a
énormément de gens donc c'est vrai qu'à
un moment donné les gens ressentent le
besoin de secouer le cocotier quoi de
faire bouger les choses plus vite 00
mobimo on va se tourner vers vous alors
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait là pour
parler de vos expériences malheureuses
avec les plateformes de livraison mais
plutôt pour nous décrire la façon
originale que vous avez trouvé de les
combattre
cela n'a pas été le syndicalisme tel
qu'on l'entend de façon traditionnelle
expliquez-nous un peu oui et on a fait
les militants cliniquement fait on a été
obligé de réinventer quelque chose c'est
pour ça que je parle de temps en temps
donné au proto syndicalisme parce que on
a on a dû réinventer quelque chose sur
la base d'un d'un corps de métier d'une
méthode de travail qui étaient nouvelles
la fameuse la femme du bief risation les
travailleurs atypiques selon comme on
les appelle donc on était avec un essai
de support novateur il fallait qu'on
réinvente du du syndicalisme mehal a la
même façon que qu'au 19e siècle c'est
pour ça que je parle de néo-pros taux de
syndicalisme parce qu'on réinvente
quelque chose
qu'est ce qui vous gêne et dans les
syndicats classiques le sujet
moi personnellement j'avais l'intention
de travailler avec du syndicat sauf que
très très vite sur terre on s'est aperçu
que le syndicalisme au but et tout un
tas de ces nouveaux travailleurs qui
travaillera typique elle est notamment
les livreurs puisque c'est la cible dont
je m'occupe les livreurs des plateformes
le syndicalisme il voulait pas en
entendre parler pendant des années j'ai
essayé quand même de travailler avec
avec des syndicats je vois bien que ça
marche pas et finalement je me suis
aperçu qu'ils avaient raison c'est des
jeunes travailleurs là parce que en
avançant dans le temps je me suis aperçu
que les syndicats avec lesquels je
travaillais était était plutôt
intéressés par leur image plutôt que par
celle des travailleurs les syndicats qui
étaient devenus comme des partis
politiques c'est ce que vous diriez
c'est en fin de compte il ya des il ya
des échéances électorales dans le sens
italie on en a entendu parler il ya pas
longtemps avec la cfdt qui se gaussent
d'être le premier syndicat de france
dans le privé la cgt qui elle c'est un
petit peu comme les audiences dans la
radio voilà donc en fin de compte tenu
qu'il ya des échéances électorales du
cas des subventions qui sont qui sont
liées à ses échéances
forcément elle se tire la structure
labour en pensant plus à leur image à
leur siège alors oui cardiaque dans les
ministères
plutôt qu'aux travailleurs qu'elles sont
censées défendre enfin la numérisation
quitter cela vous qu'est ce que vous
faites des différents ben on est on est
très au contact avec avec les gens
surtout et puis on est surtout dans le
clapet et moins particulier je suis très
très réceptifs puisque j'ai un petit peu
lancé la bataille où je connais un petit
peu tous les acteurs qui sont arrivés
donc de plus en plus lointain dans dans
le passé et donc ça me permet de
connaître les gens et en avançant en
connaissant ces gens je j'ai rita de
faire des erreurs et donc de perdre du
temps dans justement dans des des
artifices syndicaux qui souvent qu'ils
soient en train de sangles à coudre
odieux cas laurent qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire d'entendre cela le combler les
travailleurs les travailleurs enfin
10 et comme on dit les ibères
effectivement se sont mis à apprendre
des formes d'organisation je connais le
clap ont des formes d'organisation
originale qui tenait compte aussi on ya
beaucoup de gens qui étaient devenus des
hubert parce que justement il voulait
pas non plus être
il croyait à une certaine autonomie puis
en fait bon les logiques de domination
sont quand même très forte et donc on
voit bien d'ailleurs que la bataille de
requalification leur contrat allait elle
est très importante
donc ça c'est des nouvelle forme de
salariat cette déception quand même
sociale une déception et de critiques
parce que mais parce que tout c'est
toutes ces choses qui bougent à toute
vitesse en particulier dans le salariat
on c'est vrai que des partis politiques
ou des syndicats n'arrivent pas toujours
à les absorber
il évolue à la vitesse à laquelle tout
ça est en train de se transformer en un
temps guerres d'ex des nouvelles formes
d'organisation et qu'elles vont dans le
sens de l'action collective parce que là
c'est le cas voilà moi je sais pas et je
trouve ça positif même si effectivement
au bout d'un moment la dispersion
syndicale devient aussi un obstacle donc
il faut il faut travailler travailler
les deux et puis nous on voit bien
puisque il ya un sénateur de notre
groupe qui a beaucoup travaillé sur la
question d hubert k déposé un projet de
loi pascal savoldelli avec d'autres qui
a travaillé sur ça qu'a rencontré
beaucoup de 2
deux travailleurs des plateformes et des
trappes de travailleurs des deux hubert
est un peu partout en france
effectivement il m'a il m'a souvent
raconté que dans les discussions il ya
aussi ce besoin de préserver et même de
faire valoir dans le travail une
autonomie à laquelle il aspirait au
départ même si de fait aujourd'hui les
conditions de travail sont pas du tout
celles qui pouvaient espérer que souvent
ils subissent au contraire des
contraintes et des logiques de
domination très forte des plateformes
mais bon ça bouge beaucoup voilà on va
on va rester soi même c'est ce qu'on
entend des syndicats qui sont un peu
ringardisé aujourd'hui par une nouvelle
forme de combat mi temps les syndicats
c'est facile de dire les syndicats parce
que les syndicats on leur tape beaucoup
dessus aussi un et notamment ceux qui
veulent pas que les travailleurs
s'organise passe beaucoup de temps à
taper là ça les arrange longtemps sur
les 110 kg agnès canayer
c'est facile oui enfin quand même une
odyssée un auditoire qui est aussi qui
se réduit mais comme les partis
politiques aujourd'hui on voit bien
c'est la question ce soir c'est vraiment
ça tout à fait mais on voit bien et ces
témoignages montrent qu'il ya une
attente aujourd'hui d'une nouvelle forme
de deux militantisme d'engagement avec
plus de souplesse plus de réactivité
plus peut-être d'efficacité mais c'est
justement cette question de l'efficacité
que qu'il faut se poser aussi parce que
derrière
donc premièrement ça impose aussi la
nécessité de se remettre en question je
pense que - les partis politiques et les
syndicats aujourd'hui ont besoin aussi
d'évoluer ont besoin de se repenser
leurs formes d'organisation parce qu'on
sent bien que deux partout monte alors
via les réseaux sociaux via les formes
d'action cette volonté d'aller plus vite
plus fort et et dette plus donc ça c'est
à entendre et je pense qu'il faut
vraiment y réfléchir il y avait une
tentative c'est ce qu'a voulu essayer de
faire manuel macron avec son parti
plutôt de réseaux sociaux que de
militants mais on en voit aussi les
limites
aujourd'hui donc se pose aussi derrière
la question c'est de l'efficacité et
commence à se transcrit après en actions
concrètes et en actions politiques et
potentiellement loi région a fortiori à
jérôme pineau
ouais je voulais réagir aux propos de
pierre laurent qui dit qu'on tape
beaucoup sur le sur les syndicats c'est
vrai qu'on t'a beaucoup sur les flancs
10 k le problème c'est que nous à notre
niveau que ce soit
le clapet et les travailleurs des
plateformes on a vu on a vu à quel point
le syndicalisme pouvait être très très
maladroit voire malveillants
malveillants parc on a vu deux on a vu
des épisodes notamment la sphère des
friches si l'année dernière où la cgt a
quand même permis quand même sauver la
société des prud'hommes en conseillant
en désinformant les livreurs pour ne pas
qu'ils aillent au trophée d'homme tout
ça pour des des échéances des échéances
électorales électoraliste et syndicale
donc on voit bien qu'en fin de compte
quand la cgt se taper dessus parce qu on
en parle beaucoup de la cgt on a entendu
parler du 1er mai il ya des fois
franchement elle le mérite
enfin pascal mais dans ce cas notre
recteur franchement c'est avéré pour
conclure en quelques secondes
moi je suis pas l'avocat de tel ou tel
syndicat ici mais elle non je crois pas
que là le syndicat le mérite que je veux
comme comme vous dites je pense
qu'effectivement il ya des choses qui
doivent bouger
peut-être que je connais pas l'histoire
en détail que vous que vous racontez
donc j'ai aucune raison de mettre en
cause que vous dites donc il peut y
avoir des moments où le syndicat passe à
côté de ce qu'il doit faire
ça ça doit sûrement exister mais de là à
dire qu'ils méritent ce qui lui est
arrivé au 1er mai par exemple non et
quand je parlais des gens qui tapait sur
les syndicats je parlais pas de salariés
de hubert je parlais de des forces
patronale de tout un tas de gens qui
n'ont pas du tout envie d'avoir un
syndicalisme de lutte face à eux dans
les entreprises et on s'arrêtera là
merci à tous d'avoir participé à cette
deuxième partie place à notre troisième
partie on va maintenant s'intéresser aux
initiatives innovantes pour revivifier
notre fragile démocratie ils et elles
ont décidé
de changer la vie de la cité à leur
niveau de séduire les jeunes de ramener
les citoyens déçus vers l'engagement
qu'ils soient politiques ou de terrain
ils vont nous expliquer comment dans un
instant d'abord de nouvelles images
cette fois d'un citoyen qui a créé un
lieu de vie d'un nouveau genre qui mêle
convivialité et écologie on regarde ça
ensemble et on en parle avec lui juste
après bonjour je m'appelle pierre wolf
j'ai 50 ans et je fais partie du
collectif des paysans urbain du trichon
a ou b et au sein de cette association
je coordonne le projet de ferme urbaine
circulaire du trichon qui est un projet
de transition et d'entre aide alors ça
se démarre sur se tâte ancien parking
désaffecté on a passé une convention
d'occupation transitoire avec la ville
de roubaix est installé ce jardin
partagé 30 adhérents aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'habitants du quartier qui
viennent même sans être adhérent cette
énergie là ça nous donne l'idée l envie
de se dire mais là sur cette friche
désaffecté qui appartient à la métropole
européenne de lille avec laquelle on a
commencé à travailler
et s'ils ont reconstitué un sols sains
et fertiles pour y produire des légumes
installé des maraîchers et puis de fil
en aiguille ça nous amène jusqu'à ce
bâtiment derrière moi usine emblématique
de la richesse et de la luminosité de
roubaix au xixème siècle sauf
qu'aujourd'hui c'est désaffectée comment
on fait à partir de ça pour refaire un
bout de quartier et de l'énergie
positive et on vous retrouve avec nos
pierre wolf bienvenue vous êtes un
ancien journaliste aujourd'hui vous êtes
coordonnateur d'une ferme urbaine on l'a
vu vous habitez un roubaix est votre
idée pour recréer du lien entre citoyens
ça a d'abord été baraka on va peut-être
avoir l'occasion d'en reparler c'est en
2012 et donc vous vous lancez
aujourd'hui dans un projet de jardin
partagé et vous allez nous en dire plus
dans quelques secondes
benoît couteau et également avec nous
bien venu vous avez 60 ans vous êtes le
maire sans étiquette de monnières un
petite commune de loire-atlantique à une
demi-heure de nantes
ça fait un petit bout de temps que vous
avez senti que quelque chose clochait
dans notre démocratie trop de
verticalité trop peu de participation
citoyenne à votre échelle vous avez
innover et vous allez nous dire comment
sébastien lot et également avec nous
bien venu vous avez 28 ans vous êtes
animateur socioculturel à riedisheim
c'est dans la banlieue de mulhouse
vous êtes bénévole pour électeurs en
herbe c'est un programme d'éducation à
la participation citoyenne qui nous
vient du québec et qui existe en france
depuis 2016 je crois la jeunesse est
engagé vous la voyez mais vous constaté
qu'elle ne veut plus passer par les
voies traditionnelles et vous allez nous
dire comment vous vous l'accompagnez
avec vous pour échanger ce soir martap
sidrac bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice l
ère des yvelines vice président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
secrétaire de la commission des affaires
européennes est également avec nous et
éric kerrouche bienvenue sont vous êtes
sénateur socialiste des landes membre de
la commission des lois je précise que
vous êtes sur la liste d'alain rousset
candidat à sa succession aux régionales
en nouvelles aquitaine et par souci
d'équité vous allez voir le tableau des
autres listes dans cette circonscription
pierre wolff
on commence donc avec vous votre
contribution à la vie de la cité on l'a
déjà un petit peu vu en images c'est
cette ferme urbaine en quoi c'est un
projet démocratique dites nous comment
ça marche
je voudrais vous dire que vous avez
beaucoup d un fêtard mais tout ça est
une histoire collective est tout seul je
sentirais pas de faire le quart de ce
qui se passe la nuit
la coopérative baraka qu'on a créé il y
a presque dix ans ni sur ce jardin et
qui me donne la force d'être celui qui
dialogue avec les institutions
c'est mon collectif qui a derrière moi
que ce soit des gens conscients avec des
idées politiques au sens noble et des
ambitions ou des gens qui passent dans
le quartier avec qui on va pouvoir à qui
habite le quartier et qui sont moins
politisé le dire comme ça mais qui est
petit à petit avec lesquels petit à
petit on peut renouer des liens et
fabriquer de la démocratie au fond du
projet collectif à partir de clips à
roubaix en essayant d'enlever le jeu
vous avez finalement répondu à ma
question la clé c'est le nous c'est la
coopération c'est c'est exactement ça en
fait oui alors c'est exactement ça la
coopération d'abord entre les gens qui
veulent agir
là il n'est pas rose la question du
politique la question de la coopération
la question de la résolution des
conflits elle se pose au sein des
associations entre les individus qui
agissent et puis elle se pose aussi la
question de la coopération avec les
institutions parce que si on a
l'ambition on parle on aimerait
transformer cet ancien parking
désaffecté cette friche abandonné ce
bâtiment cette friche ce terrain qui est
abandonnée ce bâtiment qui est aussi
aujourd'hui sans usage et donc qui est
l'objet de déprédations et ben on
aimerait transformer ça et ça on ne peut
pas le faire on aimerait se servir de ça
pour faire pour tester un autre mode de
développement j'entendais pierre laurent
tout alors parlé de l'urgence écologique
j'entends que madame la sénatrice qui
est avec nous et à la condition du
développement durable donc tout le monde
est au courant ne quitte pas nous allons
droit dans le mur
pas en tout cas là la planète est en
train de nous rappeler que nos la façon
dont nous ne prenons pas soin de la
biosphère va nous revenir dans la figure
voilà ni plus ni moins donc on a une
urgence à faire ça mais cette
transformation à bombay c'est vrai on ne
peut pas le faire sans coopérer son
conte construire avec les institutions
alors très concrètement qu'est ce que ça
veut dire vous réunissez vous votez
entre vous vous mettez d'accord autour
d'un projet comment ça marche
alors comment dire nous avons signé avec
les institutions avec la ville de
roubaix la métropole européenne de lille
les différents porteurs de projets
économiques les associations et aussi le
bailleur social partenord une charte de
co construction qui dit voilà nous nous
reconnaissons parties prenantes d'abord
nous reconnaissons que nous avons un
problème là nous avons des délaissés
urbains qui ne trouvent pas d'usagé qui
fabrique des externalités négatives
voilà il ya de l'insécurité les
différents trafics
c'est tout c'est un cadre de vie qui
n'est pas beau alors on pourra en faire
quelque chose donc seule personne n'a
vraiment la solution pas plus les
institutions que nous d'ailleurs on se
reconnaît parties prenantes légitime de
de ce qui se passe là nous les habitants
les gens qui ont envie d'agir les
institutions avec leurs responsabilités
et on se met d'accord pour partager
l'information et pour discuter voilà on
n'est pas en train de faire basculer la
constitution française et ça n'est pas
un organe délibératif a fait hier de
co-construction elle a créé un conseil
de l'afrique qui est un lieu où on
échange et où on partage des
informations
et il fait extrêmement importante parce
que par exemple dans le cas de la triche
la normale le terrain désaffecté
ils étaient en partie polluée nous avons
eu à créer nous simples citoyens et
associations aux données de tête de
pollution et on sait que ça ne va pas il
ya d'autres endroits dans la métropole
lilloise qui sont pollués avec des
associations temps dessus qui sont
dessus et qui n'arrivent pas à accéder à
cette information là parce que l'info
bas c'est le pouvoir et mais c'est la
base de co construire ensemble et donc
dans ce lieu là on peut élaborer des
propositions qui après vont être
examinés dans les différents organes
délibératifs qu'ils soient
institutionnels mans enfin
constitutionnellement qu'il fait comme
un conseil municipal à un conseil
communautaire métropolitain ou un prêt à
d'associations une assemblée générale
d'association qui dit ben d'accord on va
dans ce sens là alors évidemment on n'a
pas les mêmes pouvoirs les uns les
autres
entre une ville et aso mais on est au
moins on a là la même place autour de la
table de la discussion
voilà c'est intéressant éric kerrouche
on voit qu'il ya une demande
d'horizontalité de la part des citoyens
il ya des choses qui se mettent en place
finalement malgré vous malgré nous en
parallèle avec des citoyens qui
s'organisent entre eux et guy qui
veulent construire on entend ce mot clé
la co-construction mais c'est pas malgré
nous ça pose pas de ça pose pas de
difficulté particulière
à vrai dire il ya une logique
délibérative représentative de laquelle
de laquelle nous sommes issus il ya
quelqu'un qui donne le pouvoir pendant
un moment donné c'est les gens le peuple
qui le donnent pour un temps qui est
limité et normalement sous son contrôle
et ce qui a été dit là c'est que la
montée en expertise la montée en
pratique d'une partie des citoyens fait
que d'une certaine façon ils veulent
être plus associés aux pratiques de
gouvernement
or on n'a pas cette culture en france je
vraiment très simplement mais quand on
se compare à d'autres démocraties
occidentales
il n'y a pas de séparation des pouvoirs
au niveau local en france une séparation
entre la majorité et l'opposition mais a
pas de séparation des pouvoirs entre
l'exécutif et le législatif
et puis il ya cette idée que pendant un
moment donné on monopolise l'espace de
la représentation en tant qu'élus et on
demande aux citoyens d'être un
intermittent de la démocratie d'être là
au moment où on vote à un temps donné et
un autre moment c'est juste plus
possible c'est juste plus possible parce
que c'est justement de cette coopération
qui est difficile entre et les élus et
les citoyens que dépend l'avenir de
notre démocratie et donc ce qu'il faut
réussir à faire s'est hissée ensemble
une histoire qui est complètement
différente que celle qu'on a vécue
jusqu'à présent on est dans cette phase
de renouveau et je crois que il faut
qu'on sache l'accepter à la fois des
élus mais également les citoyens et les
opposer fictivement ne relève pas pour
moi de quelque chose qui est pertinent
c'est la complémentarité qu'il faut
penser c'est très compliqué à faire mais
je vois que ce genre d'initiative c'est
typiquement ce qu'il faut faire c'est un
échange et une construction sur un objet
public avec pas les mêmes niveau
d'autorité mais avec des gens qui
apportent une expertise différentes et
des vue complémentaires de celles qu'on
peut avoir dans une institution à ce que
c'est vraiment ce qui est en train de se
passer pour vos pieds revanche je crois
que ça vous gêne pas du tout que la
mairie reprenne à son compte
votre projet c'est même temps mieux et
c'est mary en marchant je crois oui pour
être franc mais je le dis au maire
régulièrement je sois pas la même chose
que lui au premier tour
on n'a pas les mêmes choix politiques
mais qui contient effectivement et dans
la démocratie y est les lentilles sont
désignés a ordonné qu'on va incarner le
pouvoir et ont construit avec eux et on
est capable de passer des désaccords et
c'est alors j'ai peut-être l'air de le
présenter ça a l'air un peu le monde de
oui oui ce que je raconte il se trouve
que c'est une petite conjonction qui est
qui est sympa mais qui est quand même
fragile c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on construit avec les techniciens
avec certains des lui n'est pas encore
totalement par exemple sur la triche
on est en train de construire un marché
de recherche et développement pour avoir
les moyens de reconstruire un sol
fertile et d'installer des mains des
marais sais pas il faut que ça arrive
jusqu'à au conseil communautaire
et c'est vrai que ça remonte de la base
vers le conseil est normalement le
chemin des décisions et délibérations
qui vont être examinés étaient dans
l'autre sens il ya des politiques qui
tourne et il est déterminé à les
défendre et les mettre en textes parlés
travail
et puis il ya des votes là du terrain
arrive une proposition construite avec
des techniciens avec nous et avec dédé
lui attrape un moment mais on sent bien
que la machine a du mal à fonctionner de
cette façon là donc
et puis on est sur une conjonction aux
tirs est super mais un peu fragile parce
que cette fragilité il faut peut-être la
règle et est-ce que c'était justement
peut-être ensuite aux politiques aux
parlementaires de prendre le relais pour
les soutenir ces initiatives
alors moi je crois que en fait à travers
tout ce débat autour de la démocratie
d'ailleurs vous avez intitulé notre
échange revivifier c'est bien cela la
démocratie
c'est ce évocateur de ce que dit
monsieur pierre wolf c'est très
intéressant parce que effectivement ce
lien entre le terrain c'est-à-dire la
proximité la plus proche du citoyen dans
laquelle le citoyen est complètement
partie prenante et complètement acteur
de son action et les élus puisque les
élus ne sont pas désignés les élus sont
élus par définition ou par les citoyens
et en réalité on a l'impression
aujourd'hui à travers donc une certaine
forme de deux critiques que l'on
pourrait avoir et que l'on sent dans le
débat public autour de la représentation
politique dans notre pays comme une
espèce de rupture qui aurait eu à un
moment donné entre la représentation des
élus des citoyens et les citoyens eux
mêmes
en fait c'est ce lien là qu'il faut que
nous réussissions tous ensemble et ma
conviction intime c'est que pour pouvoir
leur tisser il faut qu on se reparle de
nouveau
et ça je crois que une initiative comme
celle qui vient d'être présentée tout à
fait et va tout amené dans le bon sens
partisane en france partisane c'est
exactement cela je crois qu'il faut
prendre voir dans nos territoires et je
trouve cela très intéressant d'ailleurs
je me permettrai de m'y intéresser d'un
peu plus près parce que je trouve que
lorsqu'il ya de bons exemples comme ça
ça vaut la peine qu'on s'y intéresse
c'est pourquoi pas les reproduire dans
différents territoires
selon les spécificités de chaque
territoire ça c'est quelque chose qui
est fondamentale et mais je rajouterais
quelque chose que je n'ai pas encore
entendu mais je pense que ça viendra
dans le débat c'est la compréhension que
l'on a de la démocratie une démocratie
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui nous est
offert sur un plateau d'argent
une démocratie ça se construit ça se
consolident ça s'entretient
ça se mérite et je crois que dès lors
que les concitoyens nos concitoyens nous
pousse nous les élus quels que soient
nos bords politiques quelles que soient
nos convictions sur des sujets je dirais
nationaux au quotidien il faut qu'on
l'entende
il faut qu'on s'en inspire moi je viens
dans un territoire où par exemple et
dans une ville saint germain en laye
dans laquelle nous avons instauré un
budget participatif
ce budget participatif en réalité ici et
c'est quoi c'est tout simplement les
citoyens de la ville qui ont un projet
pour lequel il souhaite avoir quelques
moyens pour pouvoir le mettre en place
s'adresse à la commune et la commune
ensuite des partages en fait les
différents projets qui nous viennent et
on aide les concitoyens pour bâtir
ensemble ça rejoint finalement dans une
certaine mesure ce que disait en
conclusion monsieur wolf et ça rejoint
l'exemple de benoît couteau revend soir
les dysfonctionnements de notre système
démocratique je le disais vous les avez
constaté assez tôt des 95 même d'après
ce que vous avez dit en préparant cette
émission au niveau de la mairie c'était
trop vertical un maire omniprésent seul
maître à bord
et alors vous une fois que vous avez été
aux manettes vous avez changé tout cela
comment alors oui tout à fait comme j'ai
mal de sites faut retisser le lien mais
je pense qu'il faut revisiter notre
façon de diriger noah
j'aperçois l'écran 50 ans et 60 ans et
un an mais merci de nos régions
comment je pense qu'effectivement tout
ce qu'on entend autour de la
co-construction le risque d'aller tester
aujourd'hui quelque chose qu'ils font
développer nécessairement et une
défaillance et de revisiter de
gouvernance niveau de nos communes et en
arrêtant de penser que le maire ce
policier serait capable de tout décider
où devraient tous d'essayer comment avez
vous fait votre événement très
concrètement il quelqu'un comme l'air
très très simple en déduit le mandat
conseil municipal doit voter gassion
accordée au magazine terra le maire deux
récents savent pas c'est papa conseil
municipal les nouveaux conseils utiles
pour son pavillon autorisé le maire
engagé commune à des hauts niveaux
financier donc là déjà c'est une
première que j'ai reçu si on prend
l'exemple de la commune de manière à
limiter ma délégation en euros à 15000
euros pour tout dossier ozap 15000 euros
comme il est obligé de dépenser pour
tout 4 0 je donne naissance à un conseil
municipal autre façon très simple aussi
de montrer qu'on va partager à ses
passagers des indemnités malheureusement
dans notre monde d'élus l'argent est
beaucoup trop présent il ya trop les
indemnités sont indispensables mais il
ya trop de mes collègues élus disent ils
de bonne foi à la politique et après se
font happer par les euros qui sont
trouve important d'y asseoir les élites
et des cumuls de mandats et donc dans
des deux tailles de manière on a une
enveloppe budgétaire pour le maire et
les adjoints
on a décidé de partager ça auprès de
tous les conseillers municipaux et qui
est le niveau de banalités n'a pas été
liées à la fonction elle était liée à
l'implication donc en fait on a des
adjoints qui gagne la même indemnité
qu'un est lui qui co préside un comité
consultatif
donc ça fait des choses qui évoquera si
c'est ça tout à fait à la fois c'est
vraiment c'est d'une stabilité
remarquable essai exceptionnel comme
fonctionnement dans nos instances
aujourd'hui on voit très fréquemment à
main levée je suis toujours assez
libéré de voir toutes ces délibérations
qui passe à l'unanimité ou à la majorité
lorsqu'il ya un groupe d'opposition et
que la minorité et votent toujours
contre en fait lorsque vous mettez à
main levée et bien l'influencé du maire
ou de l'adjoint qui présente le dossier
crée nécessairement un changement de
position éventuelle de nos côtes prié le
ghana démocratie ça marche comment cette
cata pl trois jours francs pour la
taille de comines que je dirige avec mes
collègues et du trois jours francs avant
on en voit lors du jour du conseil
municipal avec les délibérations à venir
si sur une délibération particulière un
élu souhaite un vote à bulletin secret
il appelle où il écrit
un élu qui a été élu pour soi gardiens
de la démocratie de gouvernance et il
dit sur la délibération numéro 3 je
souhaite un vote à bulletin secret en
début de conseil il dit je demande à
tous les virus ils sont ok et on vote à
bulletin secret sur ce dossier là alors
pense que la personne qu'il est a
souhaité ce soit exposée mais donc on
entend et guerrouj plein de choses très
simples qui semble très facile à mettre
en place alors évidemment au niveau
local est ce que on peut aussi être des
choses très simples en place au niveau
national ou pas on peut faire la même
chose il ya des six à dix qui sont
prises un petit peu partout je vous
donne un exemple que je connais en aux
pays bas il ya une vraie asymétrie une
vraie différence de situation entre ceux
qui sont dans le groupe majoritaire et
ceux qui sont dans l'opposition qui
n'ont pas les mêmes moyens et pas les
même pas les mêmes ressources aux pays
bas eux en ce qui concerne les
conseillers municipaux
il ya une personne de l'administration
qui est détaché et qui explique l'enjeu
de l'ensemble des décisions aux
conseillers municipaux pour qu'ils
comprennent bien au delà de la
technicité v ce vers quoi on va parce
que encore une fois la technicité ça
peut être un moyen de faire un petit peu
un pas de côté par rapport à la
démocratie parce que effectivement tout
le monde tout le monde votre part
confiance par fidélité politique etc
anneux ça ne suffit plus il ya plein de
petits mécanismes qui peuvent être mis
en place pour faire en sorte que
effectivement il y a une culture de la
démocratie qui soit plus importante et
moins conflictuelle alors la démocratie
française est très conflictuelle nous
n'avons pas la culture de l'opposition
assez peu et quand on est dans la
majorité on est content et quand on est
dans l'opposition on l'est pas et
réciproquement et puis ça change dans
l'histoire donc on a une vraie on a vu
une vraie difficulté
nous avons du mal à tisser du consensus
séduit aussi un autre mode de scrutin
qui est extrêmement conflictuel parce
qu'ils représentent des mouvements qui
sont en général minoritaire dans le pays
donc il ya des moyens de calmer la cette
conf lituanie t5 en faisant de la
pédagogie
parce que j'en en donnant plus de temps
en donnant plus de temps mais le
problème c'est aussi celui du
quinquennat c'est que un président est
élu pour cinq ans il veut aller vite
en général ils devaient absolument pas
le bilan de ce qui a été fait avant ce
qui fait que on a des gens sur être
monde politique qui ne font pas qu'ils
ne font pas sens alors que des des
moyens simples des rapporteurs de
l'opposition qui complément qui viennent
compléter le rapporteur de la majorité
ça se fait ailleurs plus plus de place
encore une fois pour la discussion
ça se fait ailleurs également et j'ai
l'impression que nous allons dans un
autre sens que celui qui est nécessaire
sauf qu effectivement l'horizontalité
faire partager des décisions ça prend
probablement plus de temps c'est plus
compliqué aussi
ça demande du temps sa demande de
l'énergie bien évidemment mais moi ce
que je rappelle en fait assez souvent
c'est que quelle que soit je dirais nos
étiquettes politiques monsieur kerrouche
et moi même nous ne sommes pas du tout
dans le même groupe politique au sein du
sénat et pour autant je n'ai aucun doute
sur la bonne volonté et la bonne foi de
monsieur qu'est rouge parce que tous les
deux nous avons un dénominateur commun
qui est celui de vouloir que notre pays
se porte mieux j'ai envie de les emmener
en scylla mais est ce que c'est le
cahier toutes les normes
c'est quelque chose quand on est un
homme ou une femme politique c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut que nous ayons
en tête après nous allons peut-être ne
pas être d'accord sûr vous voyez positif
les moyens d'y arriver et c'est là où
véritablement l'enjeu démocratique est
important et qui font entendre et c'est
là où il faut que pardon je vais le dire
comme ça que nous oeuvrions tous nos
écoutilles en se disant ce que propose
mon adversaire politique est ce vraiment
un dessert après tout ça c'est de la
sémantique est ce qu'il y a quelque
chose dans ce qu'ils proposent qui
pourrait aussi rejoindre en réalité ma
position cette culture là nous l'avons
pas nous l'avons pas en tout cas encore
il sera mardi au débat y revenir à cette
liste de la temporalité
tout cela prend du temps nous avons une
société qui veut aussi aller vite alors
on a une société qui veut aller vite
mais surtout maintenant je pense qu'il
ya une société qui a envie que nous
soyons efficaces c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas ce que disait monsieur cas où c'est
tout à fait vrai c'est à dire que
lorsque vous avez une majorité qui
s'installe on a un petit peu l'habitude
de dire on va balayer ce qui a été fait
précédemment
surtout si c'est une autre majorité et
on va faire nous parce que nous on va
faire mieux
or il faut bâtir sur des bris qui ont
déjà été posées et ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose et monsieur couteau l'a
finalement d'une certaine manière très
bien rappelé mais je voudrais revenir
sur ses propos très rapidement on a
droit à la citoyenneté important de mon
point de vue c'est que à travers les
quelques mesures qu'il a pris dans sa
commune et qui sont très intéressantes
il y a quand même quelque chose qui ne
faut pas oublier c'est le statut des
élus locaux et la responsabilité à la
fois du maire et des adjoints qui ont en
fait une délégation de signature donc je
pense qu'à un moment donné il y a tout
un débat qu'il faut ouvrir autour des
statuts des élus et de leurs
responsabilités donc c'est très
intéressant
peut-être qu'il faut approfondir cette
réflexion sébastien lot en ce temps de
faire vos la jeunesse n'a pas perdu son
envie de s'engager vous le constatez
elle veut juste le faire autrement
c'est ce que vous voyez chez électeurs
en herbe vous les accompagnez d'ailleurs
qu'est ce que vous leur proposez
concrètement oui bonjour alors
effectivement moi je travaille en tant
qu animateur socioculturel et bénévoles
pour un programme qui s'appelle
électeurs en herbe et dès qu'on aime
c'est un programme
d'éducation citoyenne l'idée de proposer
en fait un parcours pédagogique qui est
structuré en plusieurs étapes et itil
ida proposé en fait à des collégiens des
lycéens dé façon d'expérimenter
directement la démocratie et la
citoyenneté
la plupart du temps au sein des classes
des classes de collèges et de lycées
notamment de l'amf et l'histoire
géographie
qu'est ce que vous leur expliquer par
exemple que la citoyenneté c'est pas
juste mettre un bulletin dans une urne
tous les cinq ans alors voilà ça fait
partie l'idée c'est d'obtenir que ba la
citoyenneté et la démocratie ce fait a
été dit avant pas quelque chose qui est
inné c'est quelque chose qu'il y
expérimenter quelque chose il s'apprend
et surtout fait quelque chose qui doit
se vivre de façon concrète et pas
uniquement de chartes ou théoriques avec
des connaissances théoriques d'éducation
physique
mais comment est ce que maintenant on
accompagne des jeunes vers un bulletin
du en 1 pas simplement pour mettre un
bulletin dans une urne
mais aussi pour analyse des programmes
pour réfléchir pour décortiquer
l'information pour informer faire la
différence entre une information une
opinion
en d'autres termes comment être qu'on
arrive en fait à amener à amener des
jeunes à développer leur esprit critique
ilford savoir optique pourquoi du bon
boulot ils sont réceptifs comme mon
corps réagit style que ce qu'ils vous
disent d'ailleurs sur le monde politique
en général alors de façon générale je
pense que les les jeunes sont assez
détaché défendent de politique plus
traditionnel concours est qu'on a évoqué
depuis avant mais de ce qu'on constate
nous au quotidien et qui ont quand même
de nouvelles formes d'engagement qui
sont en train de se développer et qui
sont simplement des choses à comprendre
pour pour que les jeunes qui s'est
approprié le puits d'un eagle prendre
l'engagement ça c'est la clé marc tati
drap qu'il faut absolument aller la
chercher cette jeunesse il faut la forme
et la citoyenneté ça peut pas se faire à
l'école ainsi tout à fait moi je
je fais partie de ceux qui sont
convaincus qu'il faut que notre jeunesse
soient parfaitement informés sur comment
fonctionne notre démocratie
comment fonctionne en fait nos
institutions à quoi servent nos
institutions
ça me paraît fondamental ce que dit
monsieur lot est tout à fait important
et moi en tant que parlementaire je suis
aussi conseillère municipale dans
ma ville je ne rêve que d'une seule
chose c'est de pouvoir aller dans les
classes des lycées dans les classes même
des collèges ce ne sont pas des
électeurs donc on peut pas nous
soupçonner de je ne sais quelle envie
politique voire politicienne les
informer qu'est ce que vous savez d'une
part déjà posé la question de ce qu'est
la démocratie qu'elle soit locale
nationale vous voyez internationale qui
sert à quoi
comment est-ce que vos représentants
parce que lorsqu'on est député ans
représentent ces citoyens lorsqu'on est
sénateur ans représentent ces
territoires
que savez vous de ce que je fais d'une
certaine manière et à partir de là moi
j'ai déjà fait cet exercice on voit que
beaucoup de questions arrivent parfois
des malentendus tombe et ça c'est
fondamental est ce que fait monsieur lot
est très bien parce que je crois que ça
c'est quelque chose aussi qu'il faut
véritablement encourager à travers notre
jeunesse c'est bien c'est comme ça qu'il
revient de celestia le choix que vous
avez dire une question pour nos élus bah
moi que je me demandais justement
comment être qu'on peut être des avants
à rendre les jamais vraiment à coeur de
la politique acteurs de leur territoire
que très souvent de ce qu'on constate et
aussi de voir que voilà il ya les
politiques publiques qui ont envie d'un
petit pied des jeunes et ça fait selon
différentes formes mais très souvent
parraine les formes d'implication qui
ont extrêmement consultatif et il
décrira commence à devenir un peu plus
complexe là il ya des vétos il y a il y
à il ya une limite qui est posée par le
monde adulte maintenant reste à voir
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait vraiment
prendre en compte justement la vie
d'anna locaux construits rond-point du
pays kerrouche il ya beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d'exemples c'est très compliqué
alors bien entendu l'intérêt pour la
politique il n'est pas inné chez tout le
monde
ça dépend de votre niveau d'intégration
sociale ça dépend de vos moyens ça
dépote
ça dépend de vos diplômes donc il ya des
vraies différences aussi dans la mesure
où pour certains la politique c'est
quelque chose qui est loin et qui ne
change rien dans mon quotidien et je ne
vois pas l'intérêt que j'aurais à
m'intéresser à la politique puisque en
fait je n'en retirerai rien
mon expérience de vie proche ni pour moi
ni pour ma famille donc il ya déjà un
lien social
artix et autour de ça il ya bien entendu
le rôle de l'éducation
et puis il ya aussi le l'évolution des
outils les budgets participatifs je
pense que vous l'avez vous vous lavez
cité tout à l'heure c'est un très bon
outil mais qu'est ce qu'on constate
malgré tout ils se sont généralisés mais
pour autant dès qu'on veut passer à des
outils qui donne un peu plus de poids
aux citoyens dans la décision par
exemple reconnaître la décision d'un
jury citoyen qui viendraient contredire
un projet d'élus avec des arguments
parce qu'il faut avoir travaillé dessus
là on a beaucoup plus de mal à le
reconnaître il faut trouver des
institutions où il y a ce débat qui soit
un débat constructif autour des projets
que l'on propose et c'est la seule façon
d'impliquer les gens parce que d'une
certaine façon on sait ils savent qu'à
ce moment là leur décision aura un poids
non seulement au moment du vote
mais de manière permanente pendant le
mandat est encore une fois je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure la démocratie à éclipse
ne peut plus fonctionner parce que quand
il y as democracia éclipse on remet tout
simplement notre fonctionnement
démocratique en jeu et on met la
démocratie en péril
à un moment donné où justement la
confiance baisse et certains se disent
qu'après tout délai mocratie de type
libéral ou autoritaires sont peut-être
plus efficace donc il faut vraiment
faire attention à ce qu'on est en train
de mettre en place et on s'arrêtera sur
cet avertissement merci infiniment à
tous d'avoir participé à ce nouveau
numéro de dialogue citoyen merci de vous
être prêté au jeu alors non pas de la
démocratie mais de l'échangé en tout cas
sur ce plateau
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis de
nous être fidèles comme à chaque fois on
se retrouve très très vite sur public
sénat
tout merci à vous messieurs
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]